[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar what can microfluidics do for
you
nano scale automation of genomic
workflows now all in one platform
biomark x
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by standard biotools to learn more
visit standardbiotools.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
david king phd senior vice president
head of r d genomics at standard
biotools dr king you may now begin your
presentation
thanks very much kaylee um i'd like to
talk to you today about microfluidics
and what our version that standard
biotools what microfluidics can do for
you
um i'm going to describe uh our company
technology and products
and then talk about a new platform the
biomark x that we just introduced
let's talk about standard bio tools
standard buyer tools is a relatively new
company
it's headquartered here in south san
francisco we
are about 600 employees
we have over 5000 publications and about
2 000 platforms out there running our
microfluidic technology we deliver
leading life science tools that's the
focus of our of our company
uh we're uh manufacture and operate
under iso 1345 and we have um a very
strong regulatory uh quality uh
group given our fda submissions
central to standard biotools approach to
microfluidics is the delivery of
integrated solutions starting with
custom essay design we define and design
assays and then make it very easy for
our customers to receive those assays
we have
very
intuitive software for data analysis and
reporting
and we supply integrated uh kits for
consumable for for our consumables that
right now that run on our microfluidics
um each uh consumable is valid fully
validated and supported through our
support team
finally
all of this works on our instrument
platforms
uh our juno platform for uh
library prep and a variety of other
applications
as well as our new biomarkets that i'll
talk about later these are integrated
scalable and automated platforms for
delivering
solutions and information
we
also have
our at the engine of o-link success with
their signature q 100 platform for the
proteomic analysis um that is a very
similar based technology for microflora
using our microfluidic capabilities
from an application perspective
the capabilities i've just mentioned are
reflected in a variety of solutions that
i've listed here from targeted dna
sequencing library library prep to
rna sequencing sars kirby 2 diagnostic
detection
sample id which i'll talk about a little
later genotyping single cell analysis
and copy number
so let's take a little closer look at
what our what standard biotools version
of microfluidics can actually do for you
and i'll start start at the
very top level if you imagine
doing plate-based pcr running a
plate-based pcr experiment you mix
samples and probes together uh in each
well
each sample is interrogated only by the
probes within that well
so there's some limitations to this
approach you can let's say only
multiplex six probes at a time per well
um it can be very difficult to optimize
uh multiplexed probes if you have lots
of probes it's you've got to optimize
the design of those probes it could be
it could be complicated and because you
can only run up to let's say six or
slightly around this that level you have
a restricted throughput
so traditional multi-color multiplex for
pcr has some hard limits
and we've thought about this and and our
microfluidic technology sort of really
breaks those limits
um here
for chip-based pcr our microfluidic
chip-based pcr each sample is
interrogated with every by every probe
meaning that we put the same number of
probes and same number of samples onto
the chip onto the under the microphonic
chip but we interrogate all of them at
once so what that means is that there
are we can execute nine over nine
thousand reactions all simultaneously
relative to
a single 96 volt plate which can only
execute 96 reactions
that leads to massive throughput not
only that it's scalable our microfluidic
chip-based technology is scalable in
terms of the number of probes and
samples so that you can increase the
number of probes decrease the number of
samples and vice versa
so in summary
watering one of our microfluidic chips
and i've got one right here it looks
sort of just like that like a 96 well
plate
with the same depending um map as a 964
plate
you can generate 9000 reactions all
simultaneously so running one of our
plates is equivalent of running 196 wall
plates all at once
as an example of this one of our uh
customers the alaska department of fish
and game uh
processes um sample salmon samples uh
every year and they run
they have to run
prior to our technology up to about
thirteen hundred three four-wheel plates
um for one seven season so if you
imagine that amount of plastic it's and
i'm not including all the tips here we
can replace that by running 54 chips
it's
throughout the season it's much simpler
and in fact you can even imagine putting
one of our platforms on a boat and
taking it out to sea um whereas you
that's not possible with some of the
with any other technology
so what more can we do with you with our
technology let's let's take a look at
sample use
i'll go back to the 96 well plate
typically reactions are you know five
microliters per sample for up to let's
say six probes for place for 96 wall
plate based pcr
in our case
it's about we use about the same amount
of sample but we can generate up to
1536 probes per sample
with on our on our plates all again
simultaneously so we can get a lot of
lot more probes per sample on on our
plate
so that means that the sample goes
hundreds of times further than a 96 well
plate
let me talk about
panel design so again if you think about
a
pcr panel typically you would want to
run some number of uh assays
uh
because we have some major advantages
for for executing panel design
all our reactions that occur on our
chips are all in singleplex and let me
show you how that works
basically if you have a uh targeted or
we create a targeted piece of dna or
sample
those that samples put into the
microfluidic chip and i'll show you how
that works in just a sec and then
individually in each individual pcr
reaction is handled in singleplex so
that means when you design a large scale
panel you can make it work very easily
for the first time
and what that means is
enhanced sensitivity and specificity
again because all the reactions are in
singleplex
one one can optimize the performance of
each of these reactions such that you
can improve uh
specificity uh from any particular
reaction
you can change the content of the panel
very easily we call that dynamic panel
content again you don't need to
re-optimize the
uh
combination of or the panel design um
when you want to change a panel if you
decide to re-optimize or add another
assay to your panel it's much it's very
easy you just simply add the assay to
the panel without any real need for
optimization
all this leads to greatly simplified
panel design
and
an ability for us to design our panels
very very rapidly
and of course you can use your own
primers and probes if you so wish that's
that's uh in augment or in addition to
uh our uh
the panels that we uh provide in
our content program
let me show you uh how our microflix
technology works and show you some of
the secret source
basically
uh the way our microfluidic chips work
in principle is that we if you look up
right in the center of the of the chip
you we fill probe chambers first
um with the probe mix
we then fill the sample champ sample
chambers separately remember there's
nine there's 9 000 of these all on the
chip it's all happening simultaneously
and then and then we mix
the probe and sample together
and we thermocycle it's that simple
except it's on a very large scale
and let me let me show you that large
scale
this is one of our microfluidic chips
and it's being used now it will be
demonstration demonstrating its use by
filling the assays on one side of the
microfluidic chip you just put them in
as you would any 96 well plate
this chip is designed specifically to
have preamp on board so you can just mix
the sample you just put the samples and
assays onto the chip as you can see here
it can be done either manually or with
an automated
robotic platform which i'll talk about
shortly
so here we're filling the samples very
simply and in a second we'll show you a
blow-up of where all the action happens
the samples and assays are pumped into
the center of the chip and first they go
into a preamp chamber where they're
mixed
and you get uh preamp created then you
fill the essays
uh all at once into the assay chambers
that i showed you earlier and then the
sample chambers get filled
like that
very easily
and the machine this goes our machines
do this for you and then pcr happens
in each uh reaction chamber just as i
showed you so this is the large-scale
view of how our our chip works and it's
a view sort of under the hood of how we
can massively parallelize uh pcr-based
reactions
simple i've just
described the simplest of our
microfluidic technologies
we've recently been modifying our chip
based architectures to
explore and develop applications way
beyond just simple pcr
here what we've what i'm showing is a
workflow for uh ngs library prep
where basically instead of just mixing
all assays and samples together we're
actually executing a complex molecular
biology workflow on one of our
microfluidic chips
basically here the sample is added we
have a b
b based capture chamber
uh separated by uh valves from a
fragmentation chamber separated by a
valve from a reverse transcription
chamber
we then sample barcode and harvest so
this base our microsoft chip in this
sense is sort of like a mini factory
instead of just doing qpcr or a pcr
based reaction here we're actually
generating material that you can harvest
and put straight on to a sequencer
we also have sample to answer uh
microsoft chip workflows which we've
developed for our sasko v2 technology
here instead of
creating
reagent or creating an output that is
pumped off the microfluidic chip we're
generating an answer a quantitative a
qpcr based answer that can be used for
diagnostic or any other application
again it's the same type of bead-based
capture workflow including washing and
aleutian steps that are all happen on
the microfluidic chip
the way we've architected this chip is
to be able to handle dirty samples so we
can handle saliva and all sorts of other
uh nasty sample types because we have a
variety of dilution steps that enable us
to capture uh and do preamp uh to enable
us to have a very very high sensitivity
so sort of in summary um the advantages
of our microfluidic technology are that
we have minimized the use of pressure
samples we can run a very large number
of probes per sample after up to 1536
we are very flexible and scalable
with onboard detection or sample harvest
as i just showed you
uh importantly we can very easily and
and very rapidly
change panel content um to suit whatever
need you want and whatever need you
might have sorry
and we can easily configure very complex
uh panels with very with few design
iterations
and all this saves costs by meaning
minimizing the use of expensive enzymes
and assays
and i should mention that our
microfluidic chips are manufactured in a
in singapore
where we have a very large fab and have
been manufacturing microfluidic
technologies for over 20 years
so in summary standard biotools delivers
integrated solutions assay design
software
consumables that are easy for you to use
as a customer package nicely and
instrument based platforms
let me now turn to the buyer mark x
the buy markets
was launched earlier this year it's a um
flexible platform for library prep
genotyping and gene expression uh it's a
very elegant solution i encourage you to
look on our website and see some videos
of it
it's designed to be extremely easy to
use uh you can easily just walk up you
don't almost need any training at all uh
walk up and run one of our microfluidic
chips on it without without any training
it's very very simple to use design this
way
uh x
by mark x just won um the outstanding
new product uh award of the year at the
isbe conference uh so we're very very
proud of that um achievement
let me
explain in a nutshell how
all our applications are designed and
how we think about generating our
applications to make again to emphasize
simplicity and ease of use
i've already talked about panel design
you start with by designing a panel
we generate we're developing a simple
universal sample prep that can be
manually or
using a very simple robot
used to add
samples and assays to one of our chips
you simply run one can simply run the
chips on our microfluidic technology on
a microfluidic box the the biomark x
and then analyze the results and
look at information that you you really
need to get
so now view into some of the
applications that this this platform can
can um enable
uh we're we're very keen on our one-step
prep sample to answer an approach where
we're developing
chemistries that
really allow a unified
sample prep for a wide variety of
samples i've indicated in this
in this image covering a wide
application space of different market
segments
from animal health to diagnostics and
again it's designed to leverage our
bead-based capture technology to
generate a qpcr answer or a sample to
answer our sound using our sample to
answer chip
we have we have very flexible integrated
workflows and can reconfigure these
these uh chambers and the workflow to
optimize it for any particular solution
any particular
workflow you might have
i mentioned automation our biomarkex is
compatible with a very wide array of
liquid handling platforms
uh
name your favorite platform and we have
uh scripts and um
uh rfs our field application service
team is support team is is very happy to
talk to you about uh automation of the
biomark x it's very quite small so it'll
easily fit on any any deck
let's look at some of the applications
that where
and some of the content that we're uh
exploring with the biomark x platform
uh first in animal health
we're imagining um we're developing a
and working with a couple of
thought leaders on the on a large scale
porcine pathogen panel that is designed
to really test all
pathogens that are important in um
poison management uh all simultaneously
which means that you can for very for
very low cost meaning that you can get
all the answers you need in one
application
without having to run a whole variety of
different tests as as the samples come
in
we have a we server the ecogenomics
marketplace
um and in this case the biomarkex is a
very flexible platform for ngs library
prep genotyping and gene expression
we have a bunch of customers
that use our microfluidic technology
already
within this context
so if you look at how this works if you
let's start to look at a couple of the
key applications that are in the
agrogenome agrogenomics community
continuum
the first is sample quality control and
pathogen detection which typically
requires up to 10 to 20 markers
um macro-assisted selection and breeding
which can get into the hundreds and
thousands of markers
and then genomic prediction and
selection
is a very important element of the
agrogenomics continuum
so the technologies that are used today
for these particular applications are
pcr for quality control and
reading selection
and genotyping by sequencing has also
started to be used as well as sequencing
for
genomic selection at the really high end
so sequencing and pcr are both uh
important
technologies
across this across the agronomics
application continuum
the biomarkex serves all these
applications in one platform so what our
this platform is designed again to do
ngs library prep as well as as well as
pcr based applications so that
really address all
applications within this continuum
if you look at a drill down is more
specifically in an example
and compare how
our platform would work with assays that
are you know the manual process let's
say so typically you extract dna from
seeds of interest
you we can design and order assays um as
i mentioned earlier with our
d3 custom essay design service
you add the dna uh from the extracted
samples and the assays to our microphone
chips run it simply run it on put it
into it whenever into our biomark x
platform analyze results and release the
release the batch it's very very easy
very very simple to use
typically these projects are over 200
000 samples a year
we can batch up to 90 192 samples at a
time with 24 essays per qc test and
a very low cost per sample
now i'm going to switch to another
application which has a lot of a lot of
need for
pcr and now platform by mike x platform
has a lot of opportunity
buyer banking
some of the current challenges in
biobanking
are
sample mix up sample handling errors can
occur before or after samples enter um a
lab or a storage facility and this leads
to huge problems uh in getting the wrong
results so
um you know shipping
errors can handle be uh
her in the shipment and sample handling
and in sample contamination
processing um
misidentified or poor quality or
contaminated samples is another giant
waste of time
we find that a lot of our customers in
this space really want to know that
they're processing samples of high
quality before they waste time doing
let's say sequence runs on that and and
blowing a sequence run on a low quality
sample
so our advantage sample id workflow
solves all of these problems basically
by running pcr a pcr panel that's
designed specifically for identification
of samples as well as sample quality so
you extract dna from a sample add that
and a reagents to our
one of our microfluidic chips pop it
onto a mic by onto a biomark x platform
and analyze results
it's about 30 minutes hands-on time
with a really really high
reproducibility and we can sample we can
id 96 samples and qc in less than four
hour turnaround time so it can be pretty
fast
with that i'd like to
pause and stop uh the
conversation my part of the conversation
i've introduced the advantages of micro
of microfluidics uh least standard
biotools version of microfluidics
and um talked about about new biomark x
platform
so what i'd like to do next is
entertain some questions uh if there are
any questions clearly from the audience
thank you dr king for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks can standard bio
tools assist with my panel design and if
yes what is a typical turnaround time to
get a custom panel
thanks kelly uh yes we we we have a no
cost design service called d3 that's
available through our website uh we have
a validated pipeline with hundreds of
essay options
per target
and filters
to select the most optimal targets for
specificity and the typical design
turnaround times are within one to two
weeks
great thank you
another question we have here asks you
mentioned genotyping and gene expression
do you have any standard panels that can
be ordered for this application
um
yes we have we have a variety of panels
we have several panels that were
developed uh for use in oncology and
immuno immuno oncology applications both
for
pcr as well as targeted ngs library prep
these are off-the-shelf panels
that you can easily purchase from us but
that have been fully validated
but they can also be modified when we
work with customers specifically to
modify panel the panels uh as needed
for additional
target genes again using our d3 design
service
great thank you
next question here will i be able to use
the same biomark x instrument for
library prep when it comes out or do i
need to buy something new
no
the system is designed to
enable library prep as it is and and as
i mentioned earlier just in the example
there good genomics
um you you could run both ngs
library prep applications as well as
qpcr applications on the same machine
another question here will the porcelain
pathogen panel be available for purchase
yes
uh we're very excited about this
opportunity in an emerging area of
animal health um when the development is
complete we plan to offer this new panel
for sale through our website so please
check our website for latest updates or
contact our technical support team
great looks like we have time for one
more question here so we'll wrap up with
this one for the ngs library prep and
development which sequencing platforms
will this work with
yes that's a good question um we've
focused a lot of out of all our
development on um illumina platforms
um but we're not in no way technically
limited to to aluminum platforms so uh
our library prep methods uh can be used
to support uh any other
sequencing platform so again i i
strongly uh encourage the um questioner
to reach out to our technical support
team uh and uh get back to me
wonderful well thank you again dr king
for your time today and for sharing this
exciting technology and products from
standard bio tools we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor standard
bio tools for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you